bonjour Jean descart merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin historien
spécialiste des familles royales et
auteurs de ce livre Charles Camilla et
Diana amour et tragédie chez les Windsor
tout un programme c'est aux éditions
Perrin on va évidemment parler de ce
couronnement avec vous 2300 invités une
retransmission dans le monde entier avec
sûrement des centaines de millions de
téléspectateurs devant leur télé demain
matin pourquoi ce couronnement un tel
retentissement
il y en a plus d'autres dans le monde
c'est une cérémonie extraordinaire qui
est à la fois si vous voulez religieux
politique internationale les plupart des
monarchies que nous connaissons
notamment en Europe ont droit le
souverain une prestation de serment
devant le Parlement il y a des
interventions religieuses quelquefois
avec un passage par la cathédrale locale
etc
un prolongement si vous voulez sacré
mais évidemment rien ne vaut le Fast et
l'institution du couronnement
alors d'abord dans l'abbaye de
Westminster il faut préciser que c'est
un endroit extraordinaire parce que ce
n'est pas qu'une gigantesque cathédrale
de style gothique aujourd'hui qui
représente 1000 ans d'histoire depuis
Guillaume le Conquérant mais c'est aussi
une nécropole dans laquelle plusieurs
souverains sont inimés par exemple la
reine Elizabeth 1ère la fille d'Henri
VIII d'Anne Bollène c'est aussi une
sorte de Panthéon avec la tombe de
d'artistes de scientifiques
des écrivains comme Dickens Newton
scientifique bon et puis aussi un peu de
je dirais de d'arc de triomphe pour les
Français à Paris avec la tombe du soldat
inconnu un soldat britannique mort en 19
18 à peu près d'après ce qu'on sait qui
a été inhumé là en 1920 et qui avait
participé à la grande bataille de la
Somme qui a été terrible pour les
Britanniques ou avec leurs alliés
français donc c'est un ensemble
extraordinaire
c'est c'est la well s'est mariée ça
explique aussi ce choix de Charles
si vous voulez vraiment qui dans Londres
vraiment Westminster l'abbaye de l'Ouest
par rapport à sa position géographique
par rapport à la Tour de Londres et
vraiment un grand symbole de l'histoire
de Milan d'histoire c'est formidable
alors il faut pas confondre avec saint
Paul ou son inhumés notamment enfin il y
a les cérémonies de funérailles de Dom
célèbre comme Nelson comme Churchill etc
voilà c'est vous le disiez 70 ans son
couronnement puisque c'est la durée du
règne d'Elizabeth de quelle importance
de cet événement dans le cœur des
britanniques mais je d'abord il y a eu
le traumatisme du départ de la reine qui
était là depuis si longtemps et qui
était une reine de l'image c'est la
première personne qui a eu l'idée de
faire télévisée en 1953 son sacre et son
couronnement contre la vie de Churchill
ce qui fait qu'elle est devenue
absolument et ce qui fait que le monde
entier a vu cette retransmission en
général en noir et blanc mais un film en
couleur est sorti et qui est parti
partout donc très en avance la reine
elle a compris très tôt l'importance de
l'image alors c'était pas de la
démagogie c'était pour que les gens
vivant dans les endroits les plus
reculés du Royaume-Uni voir du
Commonwealth puisse avoir l'impression
eux aussi d'être invités à Westminster
et justement
Charles III on a l'impression qu'il veut
aussi faire de son couronnement un
couronnement très populaire
ça n'est pas du tout un couronnement et
à ça que ne sont pas du tout de
cérémonies clandestine et réservé et
truquée au contraire c'est une cérémonie
ou le peuple est convié c'est une
cérémonie nationale et internationale
avec toutes les traditions historiques
et le Prince de Galles lorsqu'il était
prince de Galles il y a 40 ans m'a fait
l'honneur me recevoir Buckingham Palace
je t'ai envoyé spécial du Figaro
Magazine c'est un homme avec beaucoup
d'humour il a été merveilleux parce que
nous avons eu une série de problèmes
techniques effrayants comme ça arrive
dans tous les reportages et il a été
très drôle charmant il adore la France
il parle très bien français c'est un
homme très cultivé et on connaît son
roman personnel ses épreuves et ce qui
est formidable c'est que la reine a très
très bien compris que il fallait que il
puisse épouser camélia après tout ce que
nous connaissons et le 9 avril 2005 ce
mariage a été très très
intelligent de la part de la souveraine
et on va en parler on va en parler mais
quelques questions encore sur la
cérémonie on parle du coup de cette
cérémonie parce que elle se déroule dans
un contexte social qui est très
difficile pour lui c'est exact avec une
inflation terrible avec beaucoup de gens
sous le seuil de pauvreté il y a
d'autres pays aussi mais je pense que
pour les Britanniques d'une certaine
façon renoncer à toutes cérémonies
serait encore pire ce serait mettre en
avant la pauvreté ou les difficultés
maintenant d'un autre côté des calculs
ont été faits par des gens très sérieux
que je ne suis pas pour faire les
calculs et qui ont estimé que la
monarchie coûtait très peu cher au
contribuables
c'est une cérémonie qui va rapporter
aussi à qui rapporte énormément parce
que il y a tous les produits dérivés et
puis il y a les retombées de l'image et
dans le prolongement de ce qui avait
fait sa mère en juin 1953
le au milieu parce qu'il a quand même
réduit la voilure par rapport au
couronnement de sa mère réduit le juste
milieu trouver le juste milieu pardon
entre garder ce fast d'un couronnement
qui n'est pas arrivé de plus de 70 ans
et en même temps à la place du Fast je
dirais les traditions si vous voulez
mais il faut penser que sa mère en 1953
affrontait un temps de restriction de
l'après-guerre et rappelons-nous que
lorsqu'elle s'est mariée en 1947 elle
avait dû emprunter à des amis des
coupons le tissu pour sa robe de mariée
donc en 1953 le Royaume-Uni souffre
aussi beaucoup les gens ont froid
Staline est toujours à Moscou enfin au
moment où Elisabeth devient reine etc
c'est tout un contexte donc il y avait
des difficultés il y en a d'autres
aujourd'hui
qui sont hélas le résultat du brexit
dans l'ensemble et est-ce que Charles on
l'a entendu un peu dans son dans son
discours de Noël il réussit à se montrer
proches des préoccupations sociales des
Britanniques
intéresse énormément il est sincèrement
attaché à ce que vivent les gens et je
veux dire on a oublié que il a été un
pionnier par exemple on parle d'écologie
et de l'environnement où j'ai visité ça
sa maison sa résidence de Highgrove le
digitte avec mon épouse lors d'un voyage
et tout ce qu'il faisait en avance il
lui avait lu tous les colis baies toutes
les plaisanteries montrent que il a très
bien compris puis alors on peut ajouter
par exemple que la cérémonie la partie
musicale sera assurée par un très grand
maestro John Elliot Gardiner qui est
aussi un passionné d'environnement et
d'écologie avec le roi Charles III ils
ont acheté des vaches ils ont planté des
arbres et il se voit très souvent ils
suivent les progrès de la nature tout ce
qui va tout ce qui ne va pas il était
pionnier pionnier dans ce domaine
de l'écologie bien avant que ce soit une
préoccupation majeure le prince de
Galles a même par exemple sorti sortie
des frontières du Royaume-Uni en se
préoccupant de ce que le massacre que le
dictateur de la Roumanie c'est osescu
allait faire contre les villages et les
traditions dans les Carpates en
Transylvanie il les a fait protégés il
est intervenu même les vampires étaient
protégés je veux dire c'est un homme de
tradition vivante c'est pas du tout la
sclérose qui sait très bien ce qu'il
faut faire Charles III il a la difficile
mission de succéder à Elisabeth II avec
tout ce qu'elle a incarné pendant mon
pendant plus de 70 ans il deviendra roi
à 74 ans c'est difficile d'incarner le
renouveau et la modernité dans ces
conditions non parce que pour lui à part
définition son rêve sera beaucoup plus
court évidemment mais d'abord la reine a
fait un geste extraordinaire en
organisant le mariage de Charles et
Camilla la femme de sa vie en 2005 le 9
avril 2005 de façon à ce que ne soit pas
un problème à son décès non il est il
est prêt depuis longtemps il sait très
bien que quand il était prince de Galles
il pouvait faire des commentaires y
compris politiques qui ne voulez pas que
le souverain ne peut pas faire dans une
monarchie constitutionnelle en revanche
va demander au gouvernement comme il le
faisait dans les derniers temps du règne
de sa mère il avait le double des
dépêches diplomatiques de tous les
dossiers il était au courant de tout
c'est un des chefs d'État les très bien
informé au monde de tout ce qui se passe
et de tout ce qui menace de tous les
espoirs il est il est déjà bien en place
vous connaissez très bien la
personnalité l'histoire de de celui qui
va devenir officiellement le roi Charles
III vous a demandé de choisir deux
moments marquants de la vie de chaque
vous avez d'abord choisi son
intronisation comme prince de Galles en
France pourquoi 1969 parce que c'est une
cérémonie très importante alors il y
avait eu un petit ratage on va dire
c'est que Charles n'était pas au courant
que sa mère allait l'introniser on va
cette photo avec Elisabeth au Pays de
Galles donc ça avait été un message
télévisé
il l'a appris en même temps que ses
camarades de collège il était un petit
peu vexé mais ce 1er juillet 1969 c'est
une tradition formidable qui remonte à
13001 au roi Edouard 1er et ils ont tous
les deux dit y compris la reine que ça a
été une merveilleuse journée il avait
séjourné au Pays de Galles dans un
collège Gallois il avait appris la
difficile langue galloise et c'est la
tradition du souverain futur qu'il soit
prince de Galles l'autre moment vous
nous en avez un peu parlé c'est ce
mariage son mariage avec Amia c'était en
avril 2005 et en présence d'Elizabeth II
vous l'avez dit alors on n'a pas
retrouvé la photo où on voit précisément
Elizabeth II mais on la voit en
arrière-plan sur la photo qu'on a
choisie ce mariage il signe aussi la
réconciliation entre Elisabeth II et
Camilla après des années si vous voulez
c'est ce que j'ai voulu montrer dans
dans mon livre
c'est que jusqu'à présent on avait que
la version de Diana là on a une version
complète la reine a très très bien fait
elle a compris et les deux enfants de de
Charles était d'accord où il y a même
été William a même été le témoin de son
père et on a dit beaucoup de choses sur
Camilla je précise que les liaisons avec
Charles ne reprendront qu'après la
naissance de Harry etc vous savez on a
vu Diana se plaindre en permanence
dénigrer Charles son mari le critiqué en
permanence dans des émissions télévisées
ravageuses etc et
c'était quelque chose d'épouvantable moi
je trouve et je raconte comment il a lui
jamais critiqué Diana quoi qu'on en
pense il ne l'a jamais dénigré il n'a
pas fait une exposition médiatique sur
elle voilà
mais vous vous racontez aussi dans votre
livre l'histoire Charles Camilla Diana
les Anglais qui étaient très attachés à
la princesse Diana comment Camilla
est-ce qu'elle a réussi à trouver sa
place dans le coeur des Britanniques des
personnalité très différente et en étant
très proche du roi c'est-à-dire des mets
vraiment la nature les traditions à tout
point de vue d'être très pionnière aussi
en matière d'écologie mais ça veut pas
dire être sclérosé Diana vous savez paix
à son âme enfin elle n'existait que en
entretenant une relation malsaine avec
les médias il fallait qu'il y ait des
photographes partout il y a même un
moment où Diana et Charles était un
voyage officiel quand ça allait déjà
assez mal entre eux mais ils étaient sur
deux trottoirs différents il y avait un
monde fou sur le trottoir de Diana et
Charles n'avait personne avec beaucoup
d'humour il a dit aux gens qui sont sur
Montreuil vous devriez vous faire
rembourser parce que vous n'avez pas de
spectacle
est-ce que l'ombre de Diana va planer
sur le
je ne crois pas non parce que Camilla a
pris sa place on sait que Charles
ils avaient une liaison en 1971 qui
s'est arrêté lorsque Charles s'est marié
il faut dire que Charles et Diana ont su
très vite que leur couple était boiteux
ne fonctionnait pas ils ont été assez
lucides c'est le prince Philippe qui a
qui a fait pression sur Charles quand il
est plus Diana oui oui absolument bon ça
c'est on peut pas dire que c'est une
erreur quand on connaît le résultat de
l'histoire mais
je me souviens un journaliste Diana
donnait des rendez-vous à des
journalistes en disant venez vous aurez
une photo pour vous et puis on arrivait
il y avait 30 photographes donc elle
existait médiatiquement ce qui est très
dangereux mais elle existait aussi dans
le coeur de Britanniques alors elle a
existé dans le cœur des Britanniques
c'est évident
une jeunesse elle était ravissante très
jolie mais mais quand elle a commencé à
critiquer Charles publiquement ce qui ne
se fait pas à dire qu'il serait un
mauvais roi en plus elle a fait des
déclarations à la BBC qui était fondée
sur des documents faux dans la fameuse
émission de Martin Bachir elle s'est
laissée
embarquer je dirais dans sa colère dans
sa rage
et en fait la liaison à ce moment-là
avec Camilla avait cessé elle n'a repris
qu'après la naissance de Harry en 85 et
cette cérémonie de demain c'est aussi le
couronnement de la reine de Camilla en
grande partie vous l'avez dit sur la
volonté d'Elizabeth II c'est aussi une
victoire de Charles oui c'est une
victoire de Charles et c'était la grande
sagesse d'Elizabeth II dans la suite de
ce mariage qu'elle a organisé le 9 avril
2005 il faut dire que la reine avait
beaucoup d'humour parce que quand elle a
fait un petit discours le jour du
mariage pour dire que dans le comme
c'était le même jour qu'une grande
course à Siple Chase et on sait que la
reine était attachée et très experte
dans le domaine des chevaux et du monde
hippique dit voilà Charles et Camilla
ont franchi tous les obstacles c'était
une course d'obstacle pour arriver à
leur mariage et d'ailleurs les petits
enfants de Camilla demain alors du
couronnement seront mis en avant au côté
du Prince George hérité de la couronne
bien sûr et quand
William et Harry ont eux-mêmes barioler
la voiture de leur père avec la fameuse
pancarte just marride nouveau mari et
accroché les casseroles qui ne sont pas
les casseroles qu'on a en politique
française en ce moment mais pour faire
du bruit comme pour toutes cérémonies de
mariage qui vient d'avoir lieu justement
on parle du Prince George qui est
l'avenir lointain de la monarchie mais
William et Kate seront également mis en
avant demain c'est une volonté aussi de
Charles de tourner la monarchie vers
l'avenir par définition ils sont il est
il est le prince de Galles il est le
nouveau prince de Galles et c'est donc
la tradition qui continue et qui remplit
très bien ses fonctions et c'est si vous
voulez la différence avec Harry qui est
certainement très malheureuse c'est que
on ne peut pas continuer à se plaindre
en permanence et quand on consulte un
psychanalyste ou un psychiatre un
médecin je veux dire on étale pas le
résultat de la consultation dans le
monde entier ça ne me paraît extrêmement
malsain parce que ce serait du
voyeurisme Harry qui sera présent demain
sans sa femme Mégane 116 enfants
qu'est-ce qu'il faut y voir le signe
d'une possible réconciliation entre
Harry et la famille royale ou une visite
express limite protocolaire
c'est moi je retiens que au moment du
Jubilé de d'Elizabeth II Harry et Meghan
sont arrivés suivis d'une équipe de
télévision ce qu'on a trouvé très
déplacé c'était pour encore remplir un
contrat disons mais je veux dire c'est
pas ce qu'il fallait faire à mon avis
bon je pense que
les choses devraient s'apaiser mais on
peut pas continuellement se plaindre
parce que le suppléant devient un
suppliant et c'est très malsain pour
pour vous les choses entre Harry et
Charles entre William et Harry il
faudrait ça serait l'intérêt bon
évidemment ça va être scruté comme tout
ce qui s'est passé à une autre époque la
crise entre la reine et sa soeur
Margaret etc enfin une autre époque mais
maintenant la médiatisation étant ce
qu'elle est il faut il y a d'autres
règles il y a d'autres prudence mais moi
je trouve que il y a eu la chance vous
le dit d'être reçu par le prince de
Galles Charles un équilibre une
connaissance un humour c'est un homme
très cultivé qui est très humain
qui est plus
et ses enfants certainement faire tout
ce qu'il peut pour réconcilier la
famille parce que c'est épouvantable et
si vous voulez il faut faire attention
les feuilletons genre the crown certes
c'est intéressant mais il faut pas
prendre ça uniquement comme une leçon
d'histoire je prends un exemple la
fameuse anus 1992 avec l'incendie du
château de winsorielsen où le
presse-philippe prend la reine dans ses
bras dans le château qui est enflamme
qui a brûlé etc c'est faux il n'était
pas là il était en Amérique du Sud donc
il faut faire très attention à ce que
dispense
un courant audiovisuel qui pourrait
raconter n'importe quoi en donnant aux
gens en vous permet d'entrer dans la
Trinité de la famille c'est pas la
première fois d'ailleurs que ça s'est
produit parce que à l'instigation du
de l'hormone il y avait eu un film dans
les années 60 royal family qui avait
déjà montré les limites du genre lors de
ce couronnement de main seront présents
de nombreuses monarchies européennes et
internationale mais également de
nombreux chefs d'État c'est aussi un
couronnement un fort en jeu diplomatique
pour Charleroi et pour le Royaume-Uni
oui certainement parce que le brexit
l'isolement les difficultés bon les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine il
y a des enjeux diplomatiques des enjeux
militaires le problème de l'immigration
de la pêche dans la fin il y a
énormément c'est un grand rendez-vous je
pense qu'il faut que ce rendez-vous soit
réussi dans l'intérêt du monde entier et
encore une fois c'est le seul
couronnement et sacre dont nous
disposions aujourd'hui Joe Biden ne sera
pas présent seul son épouse Jill fera le
déplacement parce qu'aucun de ces
prédécesseurs n'a été là aucun président
américain n'a assisté à un couronnement
pourquoi mais écoutez ça il faudrait
leur avoir demandé mais ce que je ce
dont je me souviens c'est qu'au moment
des après des attentats de
2001 la reine avait fait discrètement
rajouter dans le god save the king le
Queen quelques notes de l'hymne national
américain
discrètement comme faisait toujours la
reine la reine qu'il pour montrer
qu'elle
la l'audience qu'elle avait accordé à
quelqu'un a été fini et pour ne pas
chasser les gens brutalement changer son
sac de bras cette discrétion était et
Charles a cet élégance aussi ce qui
n'empêche pas qu'ils disent ce qu'il
pense par moment dans le domaine où il
peut le faire la France sera représentée
par Emmanuel Macron avec son épouse
Brigitte est-ce que l'annulation à la
dernière minute de la visite de Charles
III fin mars en France a laissé des
traces ben écoutez ça a été une
tristesse pour le prince de Galles qui
connaît bien la France qui défend les
fromages français les vins français qui
s'est promenaient dans plusieurs régions
notamment dans le midi il était vraiment
désolé je pense que ça aurait été
épouvantable parce que ça aurait servi
de prétexte à tous les gens qui en
veulent au gouvernement actuel et au
président Macron et on l'a beaucoup
regretté parce que par exemple on aurait
pu sur les Champs-Élysées avoir une la
garde républicaine un cheval qui offre
un cheval à qui offrait un cheval à la
reine pour son anniversaire et expliquer
par exemple que l'avenue Georges V à
Paris pourquoi s'appelle-t-elle George V
elle s'appelait l'avenue de l'Alma avant
la Première Guerre mondiale que le roi
Georges V a défendu les Français
envoyaient des troupes dans la bataille
de la Somme donc il y avait une leçon si
vous voulez d'histoire d'amitié
franco-britannique alors en même temps
on peut rappeler l'arrière
arrière-grand-père de Charles Edouard
VII l'auteur de l'entente cordiale en
1904 ça n'a pas empêché les contentieux
mais il y a eu le la solidarité pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale et une
fascination des Français de certains
français pour une monarchie qu'ils n'ont
plus avec un spectacle et je termine en
disant que Londres est fascinante point
de vue là parce que c'est la ville au
monde où le cheval est présent par ces
brigades ces défilés ses écuries etc et
c'est formidable justement on parlait de
la fascination des Français pour la
monarchie qui ne sont plus il y a aussi
des questions qui se pose sur le
maintien d'une monarchie à l'époque
actuelle est-ce que pour vous la
monarchie britannique et menacée ou
est-ce qu'elle a encore de beaux jours
devant elle je crois qu'elle n'est pas
menacée c'est tout dépend de la façon
dont les choses vont mais vous savez
quand on a plus de 1000 ans d'histoire
et qu'ils ont supporté
penser à ce que la reine a subi la
découverte par exemple dans les années
50 et 60 que des gens prochent de son
entourage étaient en fait un féodés à
Moscou après avoir été des agents
secrets britanniques bon ils en ont
beaucoup vu
je veux dire c'est assez extraordinaire
comme histoire et il y a une grande
passion pour la France il y a eu des
duels il y a eu des mésentent il y a eu
des conquêtes coloniales ensemble il y a
eu des accrochages on va tout ce qu'on
veut il y a eu la guerre et tout merci
Jean descart merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Charles Camilla et Diana amour et
tragédie chez les Windsor c'est aux
éditions Perrin et c'est à dire pour
tout savoir
justement de ces relations merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin on va continuer à parler du
couronnement dans le club des
territoires on va parler de la quiche du
couronnement vous allez voir ça ça plaît
pas beaucoup en Lorraine c'est tout de
suite dans le club